welcome to see you playing FM to New
Guinea oh wow that's not very exciting
who is that guy coupon yeah the caller
said up not a bad opening at all it's
just not the most exciting ever yeah
I've tried to I'm not taking money for
to simplify I'm just trying to keep
things a little bit more exciting King
h1 uh-huh ok age three
yeah it's a funny funny way of playing
the thing is that after if I've always
had night you form and yes prevented dad
and the question yeah this is an
interesting situation now I can consider
night h5 maybe it's a bit weird but
might be a more now let's just no 97 it
seems more appropriate and now I have
six prying this open he doesn't have 95
as this blunders f2 and this is why I'm
thinking I should have a decent position
if you cannot control the five like
should be okay yeah II five now is that
a move Knight takes five and that f file
that f file is somewhat tempting 5 95 94
our stuff like that Bishop takes should
take before it's not it's not really
working it's very close
okay let's play some move and not lose
on time to Bishop e3 might be slightly
bad I am maybe
I think noe five is a as an idea okay
wow really that's Mary materialistic
Bishop g65
now come on let's have some fun that
should be should be quite interesting
oops took their
okay i have night your phone all right
this is one of the lines at dip
calculate a little bit and i thought i
should be good now isn't this the case
now maybe yeah maybe he can go like I
know 93 no I've not g3 so what what are
you saying you're giving the Queen huh
night F to win f2 hmm 93 takes to get to
be takes me and that game continues
let's do this i also have bishop v8 as
an idea yeah bishop p8 now let's check
let's check briefly it should be a 2 g-3
Knight takes pawn takes Queen takes
Queen G to whom forward ok stall some
other ideas
wanted to go 27 but he has Quincy form
yeah if you look such simple moves
things are not to doing right
yeah that was a good game of was far to
lose but yeah some interesting ideas and
still there are some practical chances
okay wait is still a big threat now
through go bait and then taking on g3
yeah not quite sure what you should do
yeah I have to play quickly so cannot
cannot necessarily try to find the
absolute best moves mmm maybe Queens you
for now don't know time morning a g5 is
not really a threat Oh check well I
certainly had better joins us down I
think that was really close to being
okay for me again at some point
they really hated that game after this
crappy opening that was really nice from
yet but I said I just played that far to
lose okay black resins yet i think
actually i got some chances yeah Bishop
f2 wins completely now yeah they I
couldn't believe this really yeah but
Bishop f2 I didn't I didn't see that 93
now over the main thread this is the big
problem it's it's threatening mate in
three moves I just terribly terribly
played by me if you don't take those
chances yeah it fortunately I cannot
take here after this is defending and
here i don't know it already looked
interesting again yeah I should take
immediately not age four and then Queen
d6 what this takes this is this acid
nuisance move takes takes and 12 yeah
yeah I just overlooked about every move
in this game yeah it's been a long
session you really I really feel like if
you have played like three hours
straight and I'm doing weird things not
not seeing things straight chain right
here and it really doesn't have any any
problem to defend okay let's have a look
briefly at this opening I want to check
some things this should be 8 as a good
move
insisting on you five are very nice yeah
this is very nice actually I didn't
think of this at all but it's very
strong 95 is prevented and I get any
five simply very nice okay I went here
when this this Bishop here and now I'm
plenty five which was very aggressive
but interesting yeah the engine gives
equal am so I have some compensation and
this is losing due to 94 m and I think
the five is also really insane movement
I couldn't I didn't see Bishop f2 I
simply didn't see it I took a moment
here the thing is I looked at the other
line so I mean I looked at this which is
not good look at this which is also not
good and then you have to just see for I
mean once you see the move exists you
immediately see that it wins it just I
didn't consider it this is the bad part
if you really see the move and discard
it for some reason okay but I couldn't
be I didn't even see that it exists yeah
and once you have it on your way down
you see that it wins because it is
frankly very simple 93 9 f 1 mmm okay
well thanks for watching